[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de 2022
vue par vue par deux députés marie le
bec bonjour d'être député de la 4e
circonscription des yvelines débutaient
les robes et vous soutenez ouzou bien
vrai emmanuel macron
et puis philippe benassaya bonjour vous
êtes député de la 11e circonscription
députés l air et vous soutenez la
candidature de valérie pécresse on va
parler non c'est juste là jusque là
c'est au juste alors on va parler
évidemment des élections présidentielles
[Musique]
très peu de jours presque mois à peine
mais avant on va évidemment abordé la
situation de l'ukraine parce que d'abord
c'est un événement important la guerre
peut-être quelque chose à laquelle nous
croyons pas où nous n'étions pas
habitués qui va avoir des conséquences
sur nos vies quotidiennes des
conséquences peut-être sur notre façon
de le voir l'histoire des conséquences
aussi sur l'élection
présidentielle
justement peut-être cette question c'est
vrai que on n'était peut-être pas
habitués même s'il ya eu des crises
pendant le quinquennat à 7 cette
tragédie de l'histoire vous faut qu'il
nous revient en pleine face je crois que
le président de la république l'a très
bien dit c'est quelque chose c'était
quelque chose d'inimaginable de pouvoir
voir sur le continent européen qui a été
notamment grâce au travail de l'union
européenne protège et des guerres depuis
près de 80 ans de se retrouver
aujourd'hui dans une situation de
conflit avec la russie dans une
situation de guerre même aux portes de
l'union européenne je crois que tout a
été entrepris au cours des dernières
semaines pour tenter d'éviter ce conflit
par la voie diplomatique et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui
ce que l'on voit c'est une europe
extrêmement alignés hier l'ukraine pour
la soutenir face à cette facette cette
agression de la russie et aussi avec
cette volonté de s'affirmer comme une
puissance pour justement mettre fin à ce
conflit justement on va voir parler
évidemment d'après des réponses et
notamment de cette union de l'europe que
peut-être beaucoup de monde attendait
pas mais un mot justement sur cette
situation de guerre qui a en effet été
parfois qui nous semblait lointaine au
fond j'entends dire et je lis beaucoup
que c'est le retour de la tragédie
l'anglais l'histoire
mais ce que la guerre nous a vraiment
abandonné je suis pas sûr ça va être
pire c'est qu'on fait la guerre à l'est
ça a commencé avec sarajevo en 14 à
prendre dans l'ex-anpe 39 après on a eu
à la guerre froide après on a eu la
yougoslavie quand même en 1990 nous
ayons pas loin quand même l'otan a
bombardé la serbie moi je suis allé à
belgrade juste après le bombardement les
les serbes les yougoslaves et serbes
étaient traumatisés par le fait que la
france et les pays de l'otan avait
bombardé un pays ami puisque la serbie
est historiquement alliés a dit la
france et de l'europe et puis ça
continue et ça a continué avec avec
l'ukraine parce que l'ukraine ça date
pas de la semaine dernière sa date
depuis 1989 91 même depuis son
indépendance
donc je sais pas si la paix c'est la
guerre nous a nous a abandonnés c'est la
tragédie nous a revendu en tout cas on
est passé à autre chose
sur le foot vous avez raison nous avons
besoin c'est une poudrière depuis depuis
des années et puis même si poutine et je
crois que ça fait unanimité et
l'agresseur le coupable on a nos
responsabilités aussi on a
fait quelques péter peut-être quelques
petites erreurs on y reviendra peut-être
depuis 1989 et puis aussi à au milieu de
tout ça un peuple martyr peuple
ukrainien m'attire qui résistent qui
résiste très bien peut-il penser rentrée
ou deux jours à kiev apparemment c'est
un peu plus compliqué que prévu et puis
moi je m'en félicite de l'attitude de la
france de l'attitude de l'europe poutine
a eu ce grand ce grand tour de force
d'avoir notre notamment consolider les
rapports des pays européens mais en plus
le modifier le profil de certains pays
la suède et l'allemagne
elles maintenaient qui avait un rapport
extrêmement frileux à son armée des
raisons historiques des raisons
évidentes la suède qui était dans une
neutralité bienveillante depuis 50 60 70
ans il est ce tour de force d'avoir
modifié la géostratégie européenne donc
non c'est le retour de la tragédie bien
sûr puisque s'il ya des morts il ya des
idées il y avait des familles déplacées
mais c'est une tragédie qui peser sur
nous déjà depuis des décennies mais
c'était peut-être unis les erreurs de de
poutine de penser aux faux que y aurait
face à face à son invasion de l'ukraine
une division des pays européens des
visions de des pays occidentaux
et les vend le lait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui montre que c'est ça n'a pas
été le cas il a peut-être joué là dessus
sur le fait qu on était dans notre
confort peut-être un peu loin de tous
ces conflits pts avec pas très envie de
faire la guerre on voit qu'on voit qu'il
a il s'est trompé il s'est trompé par
noir yseis est ici s'est trompé et à la
fois ils étaient prévenus il a eu déjà
la crise de la géorgie que sarkozy a
quand même light plutôt pas mal le
régler
il ya eu d'autres d'autres crises ou coi
s'est frotté
à l'union européenne et aux états unis
mais il arrive toujours quand même à
contourner à la fois les sanctions
contourner à la fois le rapport de force
puisque maintenant il se retourne vers
la chine
dont c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a
l'habitude de naviguer en eaux troubles
1 c'est ça il est roux et comme on dit
oui c'est
bon de toute évidence
la
n'avons pas le même rapport à l'état que
la russie je crois une partie de la
population russe est internationaliste
nous n'avons pas les mêmes l'histoire
quand bien même nous partageons une
partie du continent européen ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que je crois que il faut envoyer aussi
ce message à nos partenaires à nos
alliés à nos adversaires parfois sur la
scène internationale que l'europe n'est
pas une puissance naïve sais pas c'est
une puissance qui cherche toujours à
faire vivre la mondialisation qui
croient toujours au dialogue interne sur
la scène internationale qui souhaite que
les instances les grandes instances
internationales soient des instances de
débats de dialogue mais qui sait aussi
quand c'est nécessaire prendre les
mesures de sa propre protection et de
celle de ses de ses partenaires c'est
des sanctions des sanctions économiques
qui sont extrêmement fortes par exemple
qu'ils ont aujourd'hui accompagné la
décision du plein et je trouve
d'ailleurs que la voix de l'europe est
vraiment leader alors que les états unis
sont dans une situation où l on voit
qu'ils hésitent
l'opinion américaine est beaucoup plus
partagé l'opinion européenne qui est
certainement que
by john a ses raisons mais je crois que
c'est très important c'est un signal que
nous envoyons aussi sur la scène
internationale de considérer que nous
sommes
une entité qui cherche toujours à le
dialogue mais qui sait aussi de défendre
ses intérêts quand ils sont menacés
alors justement pas mourir juste juste
pour dire que le peuple russe n'est pas
notre ennemi oui mais voilà on parle de
poutine on parle d'un gouvernement
autoritaire même si exotique on va vous
dire aux sanctions même si on peut
penser que les sanctions vont envoyer ce
record sans polémiquer mais j'ai trouvé
la parade la phrase de lemaire noailles
le maire extrêmement mal à passer dans
la phrase voix ce qui m'avait generis
totale mais c'est pas ça situe à choquer
c'est qu'il a ni guerre totale contre le
gouvernement russe est contre la
population russie lundi la fin lundi à
sa blessure russe bon il est revenu
dessus très bien tant mieux parfait je
veux dire ça sur les plateaux ont
souvent on a tendance peut-être un petit
peu ensemble à s'emporter
pour ce modèle lui demandez peut-être la
vie s'est fait remonter mais mais mais
tant mieux c'est 1,5 gouvernement envers
eux c'était comme ça aussi je habilité
et en même temps un sujet les gens qui
le défendent disent au fond il faut
peut-être aussi de dire les choses oui
mais mais qu'est ce qu'on veut on veut
se mettre donc moi j'ai jamais compris
ce qu'il fallait faire en fait avec la
russie quand j'entends des gens qui
disent il fait briller la polémique ceux
qui ont serré la main de footing ce
qu'ils n'ont pas c'est à la mode qu'est
ce qu'il fallait fournir vos dires fera
la caisse qu'il fallait qu'il fallait
serrer la note routine et dans ces
cas-là ramener la russie vers nous où il
faut je voyais ce que veut dire on ne
peut pas voir le l'on peut pas avoir les
deux ça ne peut pas ignorer la russie
est à la fois de tendre la main mais
c'est le problème que nous avons c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure en
introduction c'est le problème que nous
avons depuis 1989 c'est à dire que la
partir du moment où le pacte de varsovie
comecon est tombé en 1989 il fallait
aussi que le temps à repartir c'est que
en tout cas soit très discret sur la
scène orientale ne leur est pas pousser
les pions comme à la poussée jusqu'à
maintenant à la demande très souvent
d'ailleurs des pays des anciens
ils sont rentrés dans leur emprise ont
demandé cette protection par peur de la
russie quand même
la russie et pour cause bruay et pour
cause mais aussi on aurait dû on aurait
dû peut-être un seul moment là justement
pour définir les cartes de l'europe en
1989 et ne pas isoler comme on a isolé
la russie il est c'est vrai que quand il
est arrivé au pouvoir poutine avait
comme ambition avouée de
darré vers la démocratie au ghana il ya
peut-être eu des beaux mots
c'est ce que je voulais en a raté
peut-être parce qu'on a raté quelque
chose l'europe a peut-être raté quelque
chose doit considérer encore la russie
comme une union soviétique et l'union
soviétique une post union soviétique je
pense qu'on a raté ce moment là parce
qu'on aurait pu peut-être ramener dans
le giron la russie avec tous les autres
pays d'ailleurs avec tous les autres
pays on aurait eu peut-être cette
fameuse europe de l'atlantique à l'oural
en désaccord avec ça parce que je crois
que il faut accepter que c'est toujours
un dialogue musclé avec la russie et
avec vladimir poutine et que ce dialogue
musclé n'empêche pas des conclusions
heureuse à la fin je crois que que ce
soit sous nicolas sarkozy où que ce soit
sous la présidence de emmanuel macron il
ya toujours eu ce souci de dialogue
c'était moins le cas peut-être sous
françois hollande qui avait des rapports
plus compliqué avec les plats divins
mais j'aurai ce souci de dialogue avec
avec la russie et est de maintenant je
crois qu'il faut pas
inverser le rôle de l'agresseur et de
l'agresser je ne veux pas que je dis pas
ce que je
crois pas
ces jours toutes les histoires
c'est pour ça je sais pas exactement ce
qui a été dit mais de toute évidence il
paraît tout à fait légitime que des pays
de l'est et notamment parce qu'ils sont
aussi proches de l'union européenne
géographiquement mais aussi par leur
souhait d'adhérer à l'union européenne
demandent aussi à intégrer demande aussi
intégrer l'otan et moi je me rabats joie
et encore une fois je constate et
peut-être une des grandes raisons pour
laquelle ils ont demandé leur adhésion
et leur
défense que là un des points quand même
qu'on ne peut pas laisser passer à
poutine c'est à dire de considérer que
un peuple souverain un peuple libre
n'est pas en décision de choisir sa
destinée que lui puisse y voir une forme
de menace on connaît les rapports entre
la russie et les etats unis de longue
date etc mais encore une fois l'ukraine
est un peu plus souvent il est libre de
demander son adhésion à l'otan et ça ne
doit pas être la source de déclenchement
d'une guerre ou d'un conflit ne dis pas
qu'il faille y enfermer poutine je pense
qu'il faut toujours chercher à établir
ce dialogue et je braque ça a été fait
et ça a été fait même avant avant
emmanuel macron sous d'autres une autre
présidence de toute évidence mais je
crois aussi que là il faut que nous
soyons très fort et très ferme sur le
fait de dire il n'est pas à poutine de
décider si ces anciens si ces anciennes
zones d'influencé peuvent se rapprocher
de l'union européenne où doivent rester
dans le dur mais c'est ce qu'ont fait
les années 60 et la crise de cuba des
concerts proche ou d'une ultra puissance
d'une grande puissance les réactions
immédiates il faut savoir aussi se
regarder et regarder aussi nos ali si si
s'il est certes un pays où certains
puissants s'approcher un peu trop près
des états unis auraient réaction
immédiate ni quelque chose la même chose
qu'être de la suède que dirions-nous
dans le casque et à malte sont des
réflexes et cyril oui non mais c'est
bien le le risque c'est de dire si souci
de 20 jusqu'aux c'est sympa c'est disent
qu'ils sont dans le temps et lorsque je
sais pas combien classé 5 6 1
450 565 voilà donc cessé mais c'est
l'éternel c'est l'éternel sujet de la
géostratégie depuis la nuit des temps je
veux dire vous approchez du soleil vous
brûlez
on peut on peut aborder parce que c'est
la question avec vous deux vous parliez
de la crise de cuba
là est peut-être pour la première fois
dans l'histoire il y à un
chef d'état qui est la puissance
atomique qui menace directement de
l'utiliser quand tu du temps de
khrouchtchev etc et des dix jeux que je
crois que le grande terreur c'était
justement d'éviter d'éviter la bataille
qu'ils n'ont pas parlé d'ailleurs en
même si le risque existait là pour la
première fois un chef d'état arabe outin
bourbon
annonce que hilal al haboubi qui
pourrait se servir ils l'annoncent quand
il annonce en réponse au ministre à
notre ministre de
des affaires étrangères qui dit
attention nous aussi on à l'armé
nucléaire qu'est ce que c'est un
sessegnon intéressante devrions nous
aussi on line réponse à le drian puisque
je dire c'est que pourquoi je dis ça
dont il sait parler de rien et pour
cause ce moment là c'est que nous petits
ne sait très bien que en europe il ya un
papy nucléaire c'est celui de 9 ans de
la france donc il écoute la france je
pense qu'ils ne craint pas la france
mais je pense qu'ils écoutent la france
et c'est pour ça que parce que les états
ne pas les états unis le royaume uni et
en sortie de l'union européenne il ne
reste plus que le parapluie français sur
lesquels les autres pays européens vont
se j'espère se réfugier se réfugie c'est
ça aussi le rapport de force avec un
dictateur ou avec un je m'appelais sa
note au crac plutôt un autocrate cesser
ce un problème avec khrouchtchev et
kennedy il y a eu la menace nucléaire il
y avait bien mené solaire il ya eu le
menace mais mais brême le gymnase est à
dire qu'on est à deux doigts il est à
deux doigts comme actuellement donc faut
faire attention à féliciter leurs
obsessions justement de sortir de cette
menace enfin l'un et l'autre oui tout à
fait ça fait mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
que cette menace c'est la première fois
quand même que brick en aucun cas
quelqu'un qui possède des armes
atomiques annonce qui pourrait s'en
servait jusqu'à présent on était dans la
dissuasion se dire que on savait qu'on
l'avait on n'en parlait pas en gros
c'était c'était ce à quoi la chambre
quand même le spécialiste de la russie
mais je dois d'être des analystes
politiques expliqué qu' on avait quand
même un rapport très différent avec la
russie à l'utilisation de l'armé
nucléaire qu'on était beaucoup plus dans
une logique de dissuasion notamment les
pays européens et que était beaucoup
plus dans une logique offensive
ceci mis à part moi j'ai été assez agacé
aussi par les propos de françois
hollande indiquant sur un plateau que
c'était du bluff et qu'il connaissait
poutine donc ça pour moi je pense qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer le poids de la
menace ce serait dramatique je pense que
on voit bien que oui le spécialiste
qu'il faut prendre ça au sol il faut
prendre cette menace au sérieux je crois
qu'elle doit tous nous mettre en alerte
je crois qu'il est effectivement
notamment de la voix de la france par la
voix du président de la république et
notamment parce qu'il est président
aussi de l'union européenne que la
france et la présidence de l'union
européenne actuellement d'avoir un
discours très ferme de rappeler qu' il y
à une issue diplomatique à cette crise
et qu'elle tout doit être mis en oeuvre
pour la trouver mais aussi de considérer
que cette menace brandie par poutine
serait veut dire ce serait le
bouleversement de l'ordre établi depuis
des années par les grandes puissances
nucléaires donc crois qu'il faut prendre
cette menace au sérieux continuer à
oeuvrer sur le front diplomatique et il
faut saluer d'ailleurs quand même le
courage du président ukrainien et qui
résistent à la fois mais j'avais
d'ailleurs le drapeau hissé le
sait c'est le symbole hier de
l'assemblée nationale puisque nous
sommes
tous les députés oui tous les tous les
députés devaient effectivement midi ça
change était
déjà celle aussi du rôle de la france je
pense que de dire que cette menace elle
n'est pas vaine mais que tout sera mis
en oeuvre pour sortir de cette crise
pour que personne ne soit humilié je
crois que c'est fondamental c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fonctionne sur la scène
internationale que l'ukraine puisse
retrouver son entière souveraineté et
qu'une voie diplomatique est possible un
mot sur les sanctions parce que pendant
longtemps la libre le sanctions
économiques au fond ça sert à rien on
voit que c'est pas vrai que quand elles
sont bien ciblées forte et prise
rapidement ce qu'est ce qu'a fait
l'europe alors pour le pour le coup ça
peut ça pose des problèmes des problèmes
au russe dans leur vie quotidienne ça
peut poser des problèmes ce qui est
peut-être plus fort encore pour aboutir
à une solution du conflit aux oligarques
qui pourrait peut-être lâché boutineau
faveur oui d'envisager oui oui elles
sont fortes les sanctions là honnêtement
le
l'europe et sont unanimes l'europe
l'europe a tenu et la suisse et même là
ils participent aussi merci merci
poutine d'avoir totalement modifié la
carte
non mais oui oui les sanctions sont très
forts je suis pas sûr qu'elle soit très
efficace en ce sens ou encore une fois
dans l'histoire beaucoup de pays ont
vécu sous embargo et ont toujours vécu
dans la difficulté mais ont toujours
vécu avec ces sanctions la non là où ça
change un petit peu c'est que là on tape
au portefeuille des oligarques où la vie
dit on tape dans le portefeuille des
banques et a joué gvg lui hier kevin
monk russe qui avait déposé le bilan
c'est ça un des banques ouais c'est ça
donc là ça commence à venir important
mais attention au retour de boomerang
parce que quand on fait des sanctions on
est aussi peut-être on en parlera oui on
se rappelle il y aura des conseils aura
des conséquences pour nous aussi est ce
que parce que forcément il y aura le
retour de boomerang sur mon sur nos
demandes et sur nous sur nos
importations donc donc faut faire
attention que les sanctions mais là
c'est vrai qu'en effet elles sont elles
sont quand même puissante pour une fois
tout puissant ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elles servent à rien venant souvent
bien dix ans elles sont puissantes je
crois que c'est aussi cesser je reviens
à ce que je dis dans mon propos non mes
propres premiers propos c'est aussi la
capacité de l'union européenne à montrer
que c'est une puissance économique que
c'est aussi pour ça que beaucoup de nos
partenaires veulent accéder à son marché
veulent établir de liens économiques
avec nous mais que nous ce que nous
sommes capables de réponse crois qu'il
faut saluer aussi l'engagement de la
suisse puisque j'ai cru comprendre qu'un
tiers des avoirs russes sont en sus et
que donc la suisse parle avec nous et
c'est une excellente nouvelle parce que
ça nous permet d'être encore plus
efficaces dans nos sanctions c est à
dire qu elle quitte sa neutralité comme
un vrai après moi hier j'étais un siècle
c'est vraiment une c'est historique de
l'allemagne mais aussi d'une certaine
façon enfin ça ça renvoie aussi le fait
que
il peut y avoir des désaccords entre
l'ukraine et la russie
les tensions elles peuvent être audible
sur la scène internationale et que
finalement aujourd'hui plus personne en
tout cas sur le continent européen ne
tolère une guerre totale menée contre un
pays qui est souvent une agression
contre un pays qui est qui est souvent
et je crois que c'est le sens de ces
réponse extrêmement forte hier la
démocratie aussi bon et je crois il ya
beaucoup disent finalement sylvie fait
ce bla pour on se bat pour nos valeurs
et nos valeurs elles ont un prix
effectivement voyage et aux sermons
agriculture discuté avec beaucoup de
filières beaucoup se disent inquiètes
sur le gaz sur le blé ukrainien de ce
qu'on sait que c'est parti un peu d'aidé
grenier du monde et notamment de
l'europe et mais je crois qu'il ya aussi
une conscience du fait de dire on ne
peut pas brader nos valeurs a et la
liberté du peuple ukrainien aux
souffrances que va durer la population
et qu'elle endure déjà avec les
bombardements donc il faut il ya des
mesures d'accompagnement qui ont été
mises en places qui seront j'ai entendu
bruno le maire elle avait dit justement
dans son interview le dire qu'ils seront
poursuivis qu'il prépare justement il se
prépare face à la riposte et je crois
qu'elle sera nécessaire parce que
effectivement on va avoir nous des
conséquences nous avons aussi des des
intérêts économiques qui sont qui sont
liés avec la russie mais je crois l état
et tout est fait et je pense tout sera
fait aussi au niveau européen
probablement pour accompagner au mieux
les activités économiques qui seront
fragilisés et peut-être aussi nos
concitoyens quant à l'augmentation
potentielle du prix du gaz le
mais justement sur l'inquiétude des
agriculteurs
j'étais au salon disait hier
jusqu'aujourd'hui aussi
très très inquiet très inquiet parce que
d'abord il ya des filières qui sont qui
sont en grande difficulté par part par
le fait des importations tout tournait
autour de ces discussions hier c'était
on ne parlait que moi j'ai entendu
parler que d'eux que de l'ukraine jeu on
a été reçus par la fnsea et puis par le
les jeunes aux agriculteurs qui ne
parlent que de ça c'est à dire des
conséquences eu des conséquences sur le
marché français ce sans parler de
l'énergie il sans parler de duras écrit
elle a mentionné un petit peu plus
autonome en matière et énergétique on se
parle de gaza mais mais sinon sur les
filières agricoles on va être en
difficulté attention aux sanctions et
aux retours de morandi descendance moi
je dis toujours que comme disait kipling
la première victime de la guerre c'est
la vérité je pense qu'il faut dire les
choses dans un joli faut dire les choses
pour dire les choses on est sous soutien
l'ukraine soutien zelensky will outil
non cancer mais là mais il faut dire les
choses s'est félicité de l'attitude des
bleus il faut dire les choses de cela
veut dire les choses sont les droits de
vote ont chassé les allées il ya ceux
qui agressent est ce que en prison qui
sont souvent peut-être aussi responsable
et là malheureusement dans les sanctions
que je soutiens totalement indécent sont
fortes on risque également là aussi
c'était d'en souffrir une autre
conséquence alors c'est immédiate ça
sera les réfugiés là visiblement il ya
un consensus pour dire il faut
accueillir deux eric zemmour oui se
refaire et glissements qui préféré qu'il
reste en pologne
je pensais au parlement moi je pense et
d'une façon générale afin dans l'opinion
il me semble que
malo mais c'est vrai que quand c'était
des syriens les choses étaient plus
compliquées notre histoire mais oui oui
c'est une autre histoire mais pour pour
l'ukraine pour le cren le ya consensus
au parlement il ya il faut faut
accueillir mais il faut pas être les
seuls à accueillir et je pense qu'il
faut aussi aider ceux qui accueillent
également soutenir les pays limitrophes
parce que les ukrainiens ont plutôt
tendance à aller dans les pays
limitrophes ce qui est normal jeunes
talents pologne alors créé l'an prochain
launay du russe et du biélorusse donc
qu'il va ailleurs plusieurs pays pays à
surveiller jeu je pensais surtout la
moldavie à la roumanie qui sont des pays
qui sont quelques centaines de kilos une
porte dizaine de kilomètres rond et qui
nous tombent par le passé donc on ne
parle pas assez et qui vont là aussi est
aussi probablement des des réfugiés il
faut saluer aussi le fait que la pologne
s'est positionné en première ligne on a
souvent tendance à critiquer la pologne
pour ses positions et notamment qui sont
parfois un peu en décalage avec les
valeurs qu'on voudrait porter au sein de
l'union européenne est effectivement la
très grande réactivité ensuite
effectivement moi je le vois il ya une
très forte mobilisation des communautés
locales probablement
comparaison n'est pas raison mais
probablement peut-être deux communautés
qui sont installés en france qui sont
plus nombreuses qui sont peut-être plus
structuré et qui cherche à accueillir
qui de la famille des amis et c'est une
très forte mobilisation aussi des
collectivités locales de chaque citoyen
a fait une déclaration hier
recense en ce moment les hébergements
disponibles les logements disponibles je
vois la mairie de rouille ce week-end
organisera une collecte de matériel pour
l'enlever parce que là la difficulté
c'est aussi de pouvoir
parce que tout le monde veut faire mais
oui mais il faut et je pense que le rôle
de de l'état le rôle des collectivités
la capacité probablement de ces
organisations est beaucoup plus forte
que chacun individuellement même si on a
envie de contribuer très activement et
ensuite probablement aussi parce que oui
la communauté ukrainienne est peut-être
un peu plus installé en dans l'union
européenne et donc chacun se sont
peut-être plus directement concernés je
crois que
c'est bien aussi parce que ça nous
apprend à être dans une réponse un peu
pro actif face à ce genre de crise
peut-être que les vagues migratoires que
nous avons connue en 2015 si je me
trouve à nous avons un peu subi au
niveau européen je crois que voilà ça
démontre aussi notre capacité à agir de
concert et a apporté une vraie solution
il ya eu des réunions par exemple des
ministres de l'intérieur et de la haie
de la sécurité européen pour regarder
les politiques de visa qui pouvait être
être mises en place la répartition aussi
effectivement en fonction des capacités
d'accueil de chaque pays qui jouera
probablement aussi sur les la proximité
culturelle de ces pays donc tout ça est
fait je crois en bonne intelligence et
encore une fois dans cette immense
tragédie qu'est la guerre en ukraine on
voit aussi l'union européenne revenir à
ses compétences premières en fait cette
capacité à apporter une solution à 27
plutôt que chacun dans son coin
expliquant que ça devrait plutôt être
celle autre que ce soit parce que c'est
mieux comme ça donc
c'est depuis l'unité
je partage ton avis mais je me permets
bien loin que tout ceci est un énorme
gâchis quand même parce que ukraine et
russie c'est peut-être peut-être la gare
la plus fratricides puis d'avoir à l'est
voilà il peut y avoir il ya eu des
guerres russo japonaises dans l'histoire
il ya eu des guerres avec la chine mais
l'ukraine et la russie c'est comme si
nous c'était la france et l'italie
extrêmement ils ont à peu près la même
langue c'est à peu près le même peuple
il ya des ukrainiens qui vit en russie
des rues six petits des russes qui
vivent en nous il revient il parle un
peu près la même histoire l'ukraine a
été très peu des problèmes que rencontre
et ont marre et il les jeunes soldats
qu'on est russe oui ils ont été envoyées
qu'ils disent ce qu'ils pensent et
trouver des nazis comme à prague suite
voilà j'ai charente
oui mais l'égard d'un homme qui arrête
arrête donc oui c'est ça gâchis françois
c c'est aussi ça sera peut-être aussi
une des difficultés de possibles à la
lecture de l'opinion publique russe est
assez difficile pour huiler les
médiations torpeur contrôler
d'être posée
la mobilisation du peuple russe enfin de
la part du peuple russe qui quittent
voilà qui se lève pour protester qui
trouvent que cette guerre est
inadmissible inacceptable
alors qu'encore une fois je veux dire
nous sommes des peuples qui ont cette
culture du dialogue de la discussion etc
même si c'est pas les mêmes rapports de
force même si c'est pas les même degré
que
le bon dans l'addition poutine serait
fait et je crois que notre logiciel au
delà de l'agression de l'ukraine il
faudra déploré condamné le rôle de ce
monde poutine au dialogue mais beaucoup
de gens qui ont beaucoup de chefs d'état
ou d'hommes politiques qui ont eu
affaire à vladimir poutine par le passé
disent aussi que ces dernières années et
peut-être notamment depuis la crise du
coc vide il s'est énormément isolé
renfermé ces renforts mais alors ne pas
faire de l'analyse psychologique de
nombreux étages mais
voilà je pense aussi que c'est pourquoi
d'autant plus nous devons être dans
cette logique de dire l'union européenne
doit accompagner d'ukraine pour trouver
cette sortie crise et les fruits encore
une fois des proches du président qui a
eu toute une île en boucle quoi je crois
que en tout cas et c'est pour ça que je
pense qu'il faut saluer aussi encore une
fois les efforts du président ukrainien
pour dire nous tendons la main le
dialogue est apparu comme ça enfin les
isolés comme côté d'un très très isolée
guilhem vis-à-vis de ces états j'ai fait
dire vassaux non mais quand même et amis
l'azerbaïdjan le kazakhstan
sauf la bélarusse mais la bélarusse est
un état dans l'état comment la
présidence totalement guéri russe c'est
dommage parce que voilà encore une phase
un gâchis c'est à ce sont deux peuples
très très proches je pense que poutine a
fait une grave erreur d'abord la grèce
pas un pays européen déjà et
deuxièmement je pense qu'on a nos
responsabilités malheureusement
maintenant il faut sortir j'espère que
total a besoin commencer il faut sortir
parce que il faut savoir terminer une
grève il faut savoir aussi terminer une
guerre donc j'espère que cette guerre
est terminée rapidement vu les images
j'ai vu l'encerclement kiev oui c'est je
travaille effectivement je crains
beaucoup donné pour pour
l'avenir du
du président du président en guinée
craignant
pour dit peut-être juste un mot mais
rapidement d'une force armée européenne
on voit que ça fait un pas considérable
en quelques en quelques jours ça c'est
un objectif que vous
partagez rédige un rapport avec une
collègue que le mari de bec
sur sur les défenses européennes sur
l'annoncé publique de défense
est assez ce rapport jeu là où il est
maintenant avec la crise ukrainienne
très probablement obsolète déjà mais oui
parce qu'en fait nous ont posé le
constat qu'il y avait peu de défense
européenne parce que il y avait des pays
qui ne jouaient pas ce rôle a parlé de
l'allemagne l'imam al malki un rapport
compliqué avec que l'armée mais qui
exporte des armes l'îlot choses
différentes 1 c'est de choisir les
italiens exporte beaucoup d'armes aussi
avec que leonardo mais aussi avec nous
nos fleurons industriels mais il n'y
avait pas ce qu'on appelle une baie itd
l'habilité des c'est une plateforme de
défense européenne ça n'existait pas
vraiment bon et puis et puis tout ça
tout ça vole en éclats très probable en
attaque les ukrainiennes c'est à dire
que j'ai comme l'impression que l'europe
de la défense re devient ou devient
enfin une priorité une priorité et je
pense qu'on le voit bien pour une fois
je trouve que l'europe la parlent d'une
seule voix et je trouve qu'on va vers
une europe de la défense parce que
ça peut nous arriver demain aujourd'hui
c'est l'ukraine il s'est demandé si
c'était avec ceux de borgès que voilà
c'était si c'est la ccsn falloir va
falloir réagir on peut écrire dans
lesquels étaient mortes c'est bien fini
comme un bien il ya quand même ce même
si c'est l'avenir quand même qu'ils wiki
et les leaders micro d'europe 1
non mais je pense que c'est un constat
partagé sur lequel la france est active
depuis longtemps sur lequel il y avait
des partenariats avec avec les
britanniques parce que c'était l'autre
grande armée européenne
lorsqu'il était membre de l'union
européenne doit quand même dire c'est
tout à fait vrai ce que tu dis mais il y
a quand même au delà des moyens humains
qui peuvent être engagées il ya des
partenariats
militaire pour notamment une forme
d'unité dans les outils utilisés par par
par nos forces armées mais très
clairement c'était une priorité du
président la république dans le cadre de
la présidence française de l'union
européenne il est à souhaiter puisque
c'est un sujet très sensible parce
qu'effectivement tout le monde n'a pas
sans le même rapport à alarmer notamment
à l'engagement de moyens humains que
cette crise sera aussi un accélérateur
de ce débat qui dure depuis depuis trop
longtemps je vous crois qui pourtant
s'imposent à nous même quand on va faire
en dehors de nos frontières une
opération de maintien de la paix parce
que parfois l'union européenne pour les
valeurs qu'elle porte et est sollicité
peut-être la france encore plus mais
notamment à l'union européenne que nous
soyons capables d'apporter cette réponse
a été fait mais avec des manques de
coordination des manques de moyens
cohérents donc je crois qu'il est urgent
que nous nous soyons en capacité de
monter quelque chose qui ressemble à une
arme était alors on va penser maintenant
la campagne présidentielle
avec d'ailleurs promis de l'affluence de
ce conflit sur la campagne
présidentielle d'abord il ya trois
candidats
qui se sont un peu jeudi à déconsidérer
en tout cas enfin quelqu'un qui ont
été affaiblis par ce conflit c'est jean
luc mélenchon à gauche eric zemmour et
marine le pen qui avait et qui étaient
plutôt des entre guillemets des pros
bottines avec des raisons différentes
ailleurs donc vous ton posé
je trouve que l'attitude et des
oppositions finalement elle est égale à
elle même sur un certain nombre de
dossiers
on voit qu'ils sont des grands donneurs
de leçon pour nous expliquer la façon
dont nous aurions dû faire aujourd'hui
un extrême malaise de la part de ces
oppositions quant à la situation
il lui défonce marche arrière d'iron
vis-à-vis de venir et devenir assez
amusante tout le monde est en train de
se dédouaner de dire non mais moi je
n'ai jamais vu un soutien ou un
défenseur de vladimir poutine je
trouvais que le discours hier de jean
luc mélenchon à l'assemblée nationale
dans le cadre du débat qu'il y avait sur
sur la situation en ukraine était un
ouvrage pardon de le dire dans des
termes aussi brutaux mais on ne peut pas
accepter ce type de discours à
l'assemblée nationale au demeurant et je
déplore un peu
sur sa position sur revirement se sont
sur sa position vis-à-vis de la russie
sur son position vis-à-vis de l'ukraine
sur son position vis-à-vis de l'otan
encore une fois je crois qu'il faut pas
se tromper
l'agresseur c'est vladimir poutine
l'agressé c'est l'ukraine et nous devons
je crois dans ces moments de crise que
l'on soutienne non le président de la
république est extrêmement unie parce
qu'il est fondamental que la france
parle d'une seule voix c'est pas une
question de emmanuel macron va mieux
maintenant je pense que le chef de
l'état il s'illustre par la façon dont
il gère la crise mais surtout je crois
que comme ça a été plus être le cas en
allemagne nous devons faire front pour
que ensemble nous parlions d'une seule
voix c'est que moi je déplore un peu que
effectivement certains candidats
estiment que c'est un prétexte
finalement pour se cacher ne pas faire
campagne crois que le président l'a dit
à certains de vos confrères il sera
président jusqu'au bout il sera candidat
le mot est la même rétrospective on peut
se dire mais s'était déclaré candidat il
serait peut-être moins fort dans ce lot
de petites écailles plutôt comme le
demandait pas il serait peut-être moins
fort dans dans la gestion de ce conflit
de toute évidence je crois que enfin moi
des retours que j'ai pu avoir notamment
de d'habitants de ma circonscription
c'est aussi dire
heureusement que nous avons le président
a répliqué effectivement mettant un peu
de côté l'aspect campagne présidentielle
mais encore une fois je crois qu'il l'a
très bien rappelé il est président
jusqu'au bout il doit assumer ses
fonctions et nous traversons en ce
moment une crise d'une ampleur inédite
sur le sol européen et il est d'évidence
que c'est la priorité du président de la
république ça ne m'enlève ras rien au
débat démocratique qui a lieu je crois
en la personne
ddd de l'annoncé des candidatures est
question officielle par le consensus et
et vendredi et j'ai encore une fois je
crois que le président n'a jamais
cherché à éviter ou à ce défilé d'un
quelconque débat il a quand même je
rappelle au monde et gilet jaune fait le
grand débat en sillonnant la france est
en rencontrant des milliers de français
dans un débat très ouvert donc voilà il
sait pas une façon non je n'essaie pas
une façon de fuir le débat non de face
que j'entrevois jour au gré mais les
oiseaux sont seulement content quand
certains prétendent que c'est une façon
de se cacher c'est
bon je rentrerai pas dans cette
polémique de des deux structures
politiques et lille on a list 1 / / sur
les trois dont on qu'on a qu'on a
évoquée pourquoi parce que je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure il ya une époque où on se
devait de 2,2 de serrer la main ma
poutine nous prenons un public assez
normal
d'un autre responsable politique tout le
monde tout le monde c'est vraiment
désolant mérités de défense d'un
autoritaire dans ma ville il y a
malheureusement chez ces trois candidats
un petit peu plus que une relation
bilatérale normal que les gens voir avec
la crise il ya aussi un modèle sexy
nations commerciales comme information
je partage sur le naufrage de mélenchon
ça a été dramatique mais je je suis je
reste je fais un peu de politique
politicienne mais je suis je sache et ça
me fait un peu rire en fait le grand de
son oral delà de la gauche aujourd'hui
sur le la dictature de poutine alors
qu'on les a pas entendus pour pour
dénoncer l'urss à une époque donc un peu
de un peu de un peu de mesure de
monsieur roussel par exemple ir qui a
été applaudi debout même parler des
buteurs marche moi je me suis pas je me
suis pas levé pour monsieur roussel
parce que j'aurais bien aimé l'entendre
sur l'urss et c'est sur 2 mai inclus
marché s'est plus marcher mais enfin
j'ai quand-même pas reprendre une idée
émise au regard des ministres ils ont
gardé le nom du parti communiste donc sa
ferme un petit peu rires au delà de ça
c'est une parenthèse mais au-delà de ça
alors oui oui le prix de la république
s'est également notamment la présence
française de l'europe c'est normal
qu'ils se fassent entendre et c'est
normal que et je lui ai dit tout à
l'heure la france est probablement
l'interlocuteur principal
danser dans ses relations mais ça reste
quand même une aubaine pour pouvoir la
république gspr est clairement ça a été
une aubaine en 2017 avec la sphère
fillon ça sera une aubaine pour macron
pour pour pour pour l'ukraine enfin il
sonne comme une meilleure passe quelque
chose dans les campagnes dsk était était
en 2017 vous avez raison de rappeler il
n'y a pas à être aujourd'hui et en même
temps se livrent-ils et gilet jaune il a
créé sa misère et la guerre de sarkozy
la crise la crise économique on a des
mandats on a les mandats qu'ils soient
extrêmement violent ce moment abstenir
la france non mais c'est vrai un second
elle tient son rang la france michel
c'est vrai que politiquement ses
connaissances favorable voilà on
remplace sur ces quelques seul président
d'un trait une aubaine il ya là une
autre question qu'est ce qui est
intéressant parce que du bois et on
entend beaucoup à la campagne politique
et confisquer leur a pas lieu on peut
pas parler des des vrais problèmes
est-ce qu on n'y a pas dans une
circonstance comme attrazic à
l'essentiel c'est à dire que qu'est-ce
que c'est un président ou une présidente
non mais je je je je conteste pas le
fait non mais le jeu les incarnations
quoi il ya la question d'incarnation
mais qu'il va sûrement voir heureusement
car soit dans la république tient son
rang qu'il soit heureusement
heureusement que la france dans cette
affaire la tient son rang également sur
7 je dis juste une aubaine parce que
mais attention aussi aux annonces
tardives je me souviens du du de la
phrase de nicolas sarkozy qui avait dit
je me suis présentée trop gentille maman
bien points un point et demi je crois un
point et demi dont et qu'ils aient
augmenté à la fin ils remonteraient à
venir monter énormément et très
rapidement non mais très rapidement donc
il lui a manqué deux semaines bon je
sais pas si sûr la même situation on
verra je suis pas devin mais mais je
trouve que oui ça reste ça reste une
aubaine parce que la campagne électorale
est un peu confie ce qu'elle était déjà
que locaux vides elle le sera avec
l'ukraine on sortira peut-être de la
crise j'espère que la crise en de
l'ukraine au moins avant le premier tour
mais on aura peut-être une semaine ou
deux semaines de campagne vraiment
vraiment
politiques parce que malgré tout malgré
la crise en ukraine la guerre n'est pas
en france la gare et en ukraine donc il
ya une actualité française est aussi un
projet à défendre des projets à défendre
il faut un peu en parle il faut outre se
cacher comme une fois on entend
d'ailleurs beaucoup de notamment d'aider
des soudeurs des politologues qui qu'ils
disent et c'est un argument assez
intéressant que si cette élection se
faisait par des fonds sans débat ça
pourrait se payer ensuite pendant le
pendant lequel teva aujourd hui avoir
déjà entendu ça j'ai entendu ça j'ai
entendu que faute de débat pour meyer
pourrait le payer après
financièrement aussi eu aussi le poids
qu'il en coûte que je ne critique pas
d'ailleurs puisque la gestion du cloud
ide a été plutôt bonne oui je suis très
très objectif un jeu fait preuve de je
suis
je suis je suis de droite
mais je ne crie pas mon truc qui sont
partis je sais pas faire en tout cas
plus je sais pas faire donc voilà non je
dis que quoi qu'il en coûte on le paiera
aussi et puis toutes les dépenses de
macron depuis depuis un an depuis
juillet 2009 à 21 en centaines de
milliards distribués à droite et à
gauche on paiera aussi donc
c'est un avertissement se lance en fait
thomas kronis c'est que si macron
repasse ce sera un mandat extrêmement
difficile d'abord pour lui est également
aussi pour les parlementaires parce que
je ne pense pas qu'on aura la même
majorité qu'il y ait aujourd'hui ce qui
est toujours dit c'est bon ça c'est mon
héros pas se représenter derrière ça
c'est mon avis
on a connu un mandat qui a été difficile
qui a été secoué par un certain nombre
de crises et moi je crois que le
président il a aussi su montrer cette
capacité à tenir à tenir ses engagements
à tenir sur sa ligne de discours même
content c'était difficile et même quand
ça tanguait et même quand on ne pouvait
pas faire même quand parfois on
affrontait d opposition particulièrement
violentes ou des situations extrêmement
compliqué mais
galop le président de la république
effectivement les français votent pour
un candidat c'est une rencontre un peu
entre un homme ou une femme et un peuple
c'est vrai que c'est très important que
le président puisse faire sa campagne
malgré les crises qu'il est aussi amené
à gérer je crois qu'il sera trouvé
l'équilibré entre les deux leur dire
aussi que sur le terrain il y à des
parlementaires des élus locaux peut-être
moins que chez les républicains mais il
dit à des élus locaux des militants
aussi qui sont extrêmement engagée pour
faire valoir le bilan de ses cinq années
pour faire valoir qu'elle est notre
ligne politique et notamment par rapport
à des extrêmes comme eric zemmour ou
marine le pen montrer aussi clairement
qu'elles sont quelles sont nos
différences et ce pour quoi nous nous
tenons qu il ya aussi ce dialogue qui
est engagée je pense au plus près du
terrain après voilà je crois qu'il faut
pas nier le fait que beaucoup de
français
les mollets l'entrée de débutants début
2022 donc le français étaient encore
inquiets par l'évolution de la situation
sanitaire beaucoup de français sont très
inquiets par la situation en ukraine et
je crois que malgré tout même si nous
sommes passionnés par la question des
élections présidentielles en revanche il
y à aussi quand même
beaucoup de fins beaucoup souhaitent
voir le président gérer cette cette
crise ukrainienne à plein temps comme
comme il le fait actuellement que moi je
crois qu'il ya cette forme dit qu'il va
retrouver je suis sûr qu'il soit il sera
trouvé entre les positions que nous
souhaitons défendre pour après la presse
2022 et c'est aussi très forte et très
vive inquiétude de notre de notre pays
quant à la situation internationale que
ce soit sanitaire ou de guerre je
n'entends pas que ça faut être honnête
j'entends pas que ça fait à présent la
république vers une crise militaire une
crise diplomatique c'est son rôle il est
chef des armées donc c'est son rôle
j'entends pas que ça sur le terrain
aussi on a des circonscriptions donc on
est sur le terrain j'entends aussi que
ça reste quand même une aubaine et
encore je le mot et est poli mais on dit
qu'il a beaucoup de chance il a beaucoup
de chance ma ronde d'avoir cette crise a
pour pouvoir retarder au maximum sa
candidature est passé pour le père de la
nation mais on n'est pas dupe on n'est
pas dupe c'est une crise qui tombe il
est pour rien
rien rien je dis que c'est une aubaine
en français c'est qu'ils sont importants
dit d'ailleurs parce que au fond on le
voit bien enfin les dépositions de deux
à l'air est doux de la majorité
présidentielle dans le conflit
poutine elles sont très proches donc
cette parcelle compliqué oui vous êtes
européen donc c'est compliqué de se
singulariser sur ce sujet d'un possible
il se contente donc du coup oui ça c'est
un peu un peu compliqué aujourd'hui
parce qu'encore une fois le la campagne
est mise de côté donc très nous-mêmes
qu'est ce qu'on fait depuis depuis trois
quarts d'heure on parle de la crise en
italie que font les chaînes d'info c'est
c'est comme pour le coc vide on en a le
matin midi et soir là c'est la même
chose donc on ne peut pas entendre on
peut pas entendre les candidats même si
sur le fond nous sommes nous sommes un
parti un parti européen quand même nous
avons fait sur une histoire européenne
nous avons une branche centre-droit très
européenne une branche à droite
européenne à sa façon on est un grand
parti on a l'eau on a nous on a nos
idées là-dessus mais si vous avez vous
même un enfant de giscard de s'amuser un
peu sans jésus un enfant de l'udf qui
acquit à qui a rejoint les aime le foot
et lorsque rien devant l'album voilà
donc on n'entend personne aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que je trouve une fois
vous le dis c'est une aubaine pour
trahir la république je pense que tu en
désaccord sur c'est sur cette analyse
je comprends que pour les candidats la
situation est un peu compliquée parce
qu'effectivement ça reste un sujet
majeur de préoccupation mais encore une
fois je n'ai pas ou alors vous devriez
vous inquiéter si c'est ça votre ligne
politique mais ce n'est pas une campagne
contre emmanuel macron théoriquement
c'est une campagne où chaque candidat
bien présente et quelle est sa vision
pour le pays moi je suis très étonné de
cette espèce d'attentes de nos
oppositions de voir emmanuel maintenant
rentrer en campagne nous défendrons
notre bilan nous défendrons les actions
que nous avons engagées nous défendrons
la politique que nous voulons conduire
dans les années à venir et encore une
fois nous sommes énormément sur le
terrain ces derniers mois pour pour en
parler et pour échanger avec avec nos
concitoyens je crois que libre à valérie
pécresse encore une fois de mener sa
campagne de m 2 le fait de mettre les
thèmes qui sait peut-être pas plus mal
qu'on parle pas de valérie pécresse en
semant puisque vous le bashing un petit
pécresse dedans marchand depuis un mois
vaut mieux peut-être que vous la laisse
échapper quelques jours c'est pas mal
bah
justement cela dit vous avez raison
c'est est vrai que la première partie de
la campagne
normal puisque c'est des opposants très
anti macron et c'est vrai que le conflit
international fait que c'est plus
compliqué d'être anti mac ont
aujourd'hui voilà un c'est un peu
d'annoncés en désaccord mais je crois
pas que les gens attendent jeudi parce
que les gens et donc ça mais c'était
c'est savoir s'ils sont probants
la tonalité de la compagnie était comme
ça les extrêmes tout le monde
doit apporter d'une même voix le fait de
dire nous sommes du niger le président
de la république non pas parce que
c'était manuel macron mais parce que il
porte la voix de la france et que
effectivement la france est une
puissance nucléaire la france est à la
présidence de l'union européenne la
france a une capacité à une véritable et
qui constitue et donc nous sommes
regardés que nous voulions nous sommes
regardés et dont il se peut être une
aubaine le devoir le devoir de nos
oppositions et pardon de le dire parce
que je suis dans la majorité donc c'est
ça ça peut paraître un peu subjectif
mais le devoir des oppositions c'est de
s'aligner dans le président république
en revanche le devoir d opposition si et
puisque nous sommes dans une période de
campagne c'est de présenter leur projet
mon sens et on n'est pas obligé d'agir à
ce chat très intéressant de dire on ne
veut plus du président de la république
mais on n'attend qu'une chose c'est
qu'il arrive comme le messie dont quatre
de la campagne présidentielle je veux
dire à la fin c'est pas ces projet
contre projet et pas personnes contre
personne ils sont libres d'avancer sur
les sujets qui leur tiennent à coeur et
hier c'était il ya beaucoup que cette
crise est une aubaine pour président la
pluie les autres candidats je suppose
qu'il faut campagne enfin moi je pars
pour valérie que j'en suis sûr parce que
c'est tous les jours tous les tous les
midis tous les soirs mais pour les
autres candidats c'est la même chose
simplement la crise un peu étouffé cette
campagne on ne peut pas dire le
contraire pour le comité c'était déjà le
cas pour pour la crise du crédit en
particulier
dans l'histoire des campagnes
présidentielles
particulière ce contexte le contexte est
particulier le
le contexte n'est pas non plus
extrêmement facile pour le président
nicolas le jour les particuliers des
capacités de aussi faire valoir ses
idées alors que effectivement les
français ont les yeux et moi moi aussi
vous aussi probablement ont les yeux
rivés sur notamment la situation en
ukraine actuellement mais mes parents il
ya aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on parle
beaucoup de la crise ukrainienne sur les
dents les dans les médias etc mais enfin
pardon égard des dizaines et parce que
c'est l'obligation de cette campagne qui
est assez différente et des dizaines
d'émissions politiques de débats où tous
les candidats sont invités chacun leur
tour où ils ont la capacité de porter
aussi leurs sujets autres que l'ukraine
alors on va parler un peu de politique
justement
vous avez cosigné une tribune qui est de
julien aubert justement sur parce que on
dit il ya eu cette critique de valérie
pécresse qui me blesse et macro hobbies
quoi il vous dit pas du tout on peut pas
dire qu emmanuel macron soit proche de
nos valeurs et soit le meilleur
représentant de la droite en quoi
valérie pécresse est elle meilleure
représentante de la droite que qu'est
venu le sait c'est que moi qu'on n'est
pas le représentant de la droite il ne
l'est pas c'est pas possible ou alors il
ya un certain nombre de gens de valeur
de ces cas là je suis tout comme eric
woerth qui viennent de là je suis tout
dans ces gars-là mots si je suis
toulousain il y a c'est depuis le début
de la vème république comment marche la
politique française elle marche avec un
socle d'un parti il a peut être un parti
de droite comme ça peut être un parti de
gauche qui s'ouvre qui s'ouvre à des
alliances
ça a été le cas ce qu'a fait
giscard d'estaing 74 chirac on nous on
ouvre le louvre la base pour pouvoir
justement gérer avec des sensibilités
différentes l'ump à l'époque je viens de
l'udf encore une fois donc l'ump c'était
quoi ce regroupement du regroupement de
l'ouverture là ma chronique pardonnez
moi l'expression de la baronnie spa sa
macro ni ses impôts comment on met tout
le monde dedans avec des sensibilités
totalement différente marie de weck
gagnent là brad mais elle sera avec dans
une majorité ou avec ce jeu de mots théo
caudry de chevènement de marisol
touraine isabelle guilbeault s'est pas
mais je ne saurais pas faire moi c'est
ça je veux dire la nôtre avec à faire ce
que je sais c est ce que c'est pas la
fin de cette coupure qui a en effet
bouleversé la cinquième boutique pendant
des années entre la gauche et la droite
j'explique ça c'est sa fille les mains
d'autres clivages qui essaient qui ont
défait les pro-européens les autres on
repère les populistes et dans le
naufrage a pris les mix de gauche c'est
pas le problème c'est pas une question
de coupure c'est une question de le
socle de convictions c'est à dire vous
me posez une question je vous réponds
oui nous sommes de droite nous ouvrons
nos nos sensibilités nos partis à des
alliés du délit le centre et ses partis
du centre ça c'est de la politique c'est
la théorie des trois cercles de
mitterrand d'abord on rassemble son camp
et on commence à s'allier avec les
autres et troisièmement on va les voir
chez l'adversaire bon c'est un peu c'est
un peu ça la politique veut dire cécile
b à ba
le maquereau nice si on peut appeler ça
du maquereau nice je ne sais pas combien
je sais pas ce que ça mais moi j'adore
je disais avec moi je ne sais pas ce que
c'est parce que ça veut dire qu'on va
gouverner avec des gens avec qui je ne
suis pas d'accord c'est à dire que
demain je les gouverner avec des gens de
gauche avec des gens qui viennent
peut-être du parti communiste des gens
qui viennent comme chevènement d'une
gauche rep est ok mais aussi sur quatre
saints essentielle pourquoi pas une
chose est sûre il doit revenir sur
l'ukraine c'est pas le sujet on n'est
pas complètement unique les gens bien et
lorsque le dire par là c'est que ce soit
on a des convictions les garde à droite
ou à gauche au centre mais on peut pas
mettre tout le monde dans un pot commun
c'est ça un peu ce que je reproche un
peu l'âme acronis et que moi je ne peux
pas
ils ont pas la même mais que lundi selon
lesquelles anne marie mais que va faire
eric woerth justement avec marisol
touraine elisabeth guigou jean pierre
chevènement c'est toujours la même
question qu'on peut se poser il y a un
mais est ce que ça veut pas dire plus
profondément que cette rupture qui est
celle de 2017 et puisque ça en un finira
c'était la fin de la coupure droite
gauche en tout cas dans cette élection
elle est plus profonde qu'on ne pensait
pas ce qu'il ya en effet les 2 théo il
ya ceux qui ont dit c'est une parenthèse
et on va revenir à la coupure anciennes
et puis et puis ce convoi se passer
aujourd'hui qui est peut-être que cette
cette fin de la droite et la gauche elle
était plus profonde que semble le penser
on verra on verra à l'élection je ne
suis pas sûr il ya eu un concours de
circonstances en 2010 est un concours de
circonstances et l affaire fillon là ya
pas de concours de circonstance j'irai
pas jusque là mais je répète mon île ne
situation vis à une situation il ya une
aubaine on verra si la macro ni un prime
parce que pour l'instant les territoires
les candidats de poids dans ma tension
sont plutôt rares par rapport à nous qui
sommes à perdre la partie territoriale
j'en ai mairie de mesquer et les
partants le mot de l'histoire aussi mais
une histoire le le même à nous la ferons
c'est quelque chose de récent c'est ça
que je veux dire c'est qu'il n'a pas
encore cette imprégnation des
territoires c'est ce qui fait aussi
peut-être aussi une faiblesse mais ce
que j'ai appris c'est que peut-être
qu'on est face à quelque chose je n'en
sais rien mais moi j'aurai du mal voilà
j'aurai du mal parce que j'ai des
convictions moi j'avais des convictions
libérales européennes et social c'était
le triptyque giscardien de l'époque à
passer de l'autre côté
ils ont des collections très différentes
et vous et bien écoutez ils ont évolué
peut-être dans la vie peut-être que pour
mary warlick diary le bec a évolué aussi
tout le monde évolue même en faveur d'un
tas collègues à travailler pour valérie
pécresse aller en marche aujourd'hui
dire
pourquoi pas moi je respecte tout le
monde il n'y a aucun souci moi j'ai du
mal à le faire ce que je veux dire par
là c'est et en plus si je le faisais je
le ferai pas deux mois avant l'élection
présidentielle parce que là c'est plus
de la conviction c'est de l'opportunisme
donc on peut pas faire ça si on le fait
on le fait à une période
déjà effectivement il ya je pense moi
qui suis issu de la droite il ya déjà
effectivement une division je pense
entre nous de ce que doit incarner la
droite ne crois pas que ce soit une
question de parti je crois que pour le
coup c'est un peu une question de portée
par deux personnes si je peux dire ça
parce que bon les parties évoluent dans
leur vie et c'est moi aujourd'hui j'ai
le sentiment que ce qui porte la parole
de la droite et je ne dis pas
je ne dis pas des députés comme philippe
ou comme d'autres élus avec qui je peux
travailler qui sont issus d'un
terme l'intégralité des maires de ma
circonscription sont plutôt centre ou
plutôt de droite certains se chez nous
et d'autres sont plus touchés gérait
plus un spa une question de parti c'est
une question de personne moi aujourd'hui
je veux c'est un point fondamental je ne
me sens pas représenté par la vision de
la droite qui est défendu par valérie
pécresse par eric ciotti par ce qu'ils
sont on va dire les têtes de pont
ensuite je crois que ceux qui ce que
philippe accuse de vouloir ni
d'opportunisme politique je crois
surtout que c'est la reconnaissance dans
le monde oui oui ce chemin je ne serai
pas me dire que c'est l'opportunisme que
certains rallyes le président sur le
tard soit parce qu'ils ont pu évoluer
dans leur conviction soit soit pour
d'autres raisons je crois c'est surtout
la reconnaissance que le travail qui a
été engagé par le président de la
république au cours de ces cinq années
dans lequel il a exercé son mandat a
permis de transformer et de réformer
notre notre pays en profondeur et je
crois que notamment l'essence du
maquereau nisme c'est aussi cette envie
de gens issus d'un droit issu de la
gauche de dire au fond on veut la même
chose on veut le même objectif on veut
que la france elle rayonne sur la scène
internationale on veut que les gens qui
les étudiants qui étudient dans notre
pays ils trouvent leur voie
professionnelle que ceux qui sont amenés
à évoluer dans leur parcours ils
trouvent leur compte que chacun soit
respecté dans sa différence dont je
crois que c'est ça et que finalement
c'est cette capacité des gens de droite
et de gauche de se réunir autour d'un
homme pour porter ses capacités réforme
aujourd'hui la cote de popularité la
confiance qu'on a dans le présent la
république c'est je crois le résultat
aussi de cinq ans de preuve d'engagement
que on a été capable de conduire à bien
sa réforme alors que nous venons
effectivement d'horizons politiques
politiques différents et puis pardon moi
je te reverrai un peu la balle on
n'arrête plus qu'en marche a
certainement cesser ses défauts mais moi
je m'interroge quand je vois si on prend
un exemple dont les yvelines
françois-xavier bellamy je ne parle pas
du parrainage je parle de ses
déclarations sur un éventuel deuxième
tour les parades face c'est réglé ça y
est mais je veux dire je sors la
question du parrainage parce que j'ai la
preuve intime conviction qu'on peut
parrainer quelqu'un parce qu'on est moi
qui semblaient les plus pressants mais
ce sont forcément le soutenir et je
crois qu'on devrait beaucoup plus enfin
porter ce discours pour notamment
conforté les élus qui parfois peuvent
être un peu menacé entre guillemets dans
le parrainage qui les apporte mais pour
ça que j'avais des amis qui dit au
second tour je voterai pour eric zemmour
plutôt que ma part ne s'est pas dit oui
mais où eric ciotti mais si on prend
quelqu'un du territoire pardon c'est pas
une question de est-ce que c'est des
bonnes valeurs ou des mauvaises valeurs
c'est juste où va la droite en réalité
françois-xavier bellamy c'est une figure
importante de la droite qui l'avait
conduit la liste du parti les
républicains aux européennes eric ciotti
c'est une figure importante de la boîte
il est arrivé en tête je crois en la
primaire et est deuxième juste derrière
compte c'est une personnalité l'a10 moi
je soutiendrai à eric ciotti oui
effectivement c'est un droit que je suis
et que je nous fais un carnet filtrage
des problèmes ce grand écart ce cas-là
mois l'appareil si on fait de la
politique moi j'envoie l'appareil jeudi
commente marie de weck peu dans son
groupe parlementaire si j'ai avec des
gens qui viennent de la gauche et dans
ceux qui vont voter peut-être quelque
chose d'autre peut-être un jour si
maintenant on dépense ce groupe e en
béton qui sait puisque la belle amie et
dans la haie dans la situation où
valérie pécresse n'est pas dans second
tour et il dit je voterai émaux moi je
pose la question si
mais qu'on n'est pas au second tour pour
les sondages je l'aimé à part s'y est
maintenu m'attendais pas au second tour
probable qu'il le soit mais admettons
qu'il ne soit pas que vont faire les
députés en marche qui viennent de la
gauche et que vont faire les députés en
marche qui viennent de la droite moi
j'en rends la pareille c'est quoi c'est
quoi la ligne et puis quand tu dis que
le les cinq ans de la macro ni ont été
exemplaires avec plein de plaintes de
plein de projets etc moi je dis que plus
tôt ça a été un échec justement parce
qu'il n'y avait pas de ligne directrice
parce qu'il y avait des députés qu'il
n'est de la gauche avec une certaine
mais on le voyait sur les sujets on le
voyait sur les sujets qu'il y avait une
fracture quand on vient de la gauche ou
canton et de la droite populaire du
centre le voyelles de démission venant
d'un port ni d'ailleurs italiens dont
nous d'ailleurs parce que sur les sujets
de société on allait bientôt tomber des
libertés vient pas vous aussi votre
candidate était pas j'ai pardonné ce que
si emmanuel macron était au deuxième
tour et pas votre candidate c'est
compliqué mais je vous réponds je vais
vous répondre parce que j'ai l'habitude
de répondre mais ça m'embête de répondre
parce que je voudrais que nous ayons
déjà discours second tour donc je me
projette que sur ça mais promettre que
sur ça c'est un peu dommage de dire une
goutte et parce que le fait de répondre
à votre question de la muzelle une
erreur mais l'ami final une erreur
j'aime beaucoup françois xavier pour
plein de raisons mais je trouve qu'on
fait une erreur à répondre à ces
questions de journalistes je sais parce
que c'est vrai que lorsque on verra bien
moi hier on a vu avec versailles aille
en finale de la coupe de maïs j'ai pas
dit tiens si versailles n'y allez pas je
vais je vais je vais supporter quelle
équipe non voilà c'est un peu c'est un
peu ça qui manque qui m'intéresse donc
voilà bon ils se renvoient la balle
je croyais appareils de finalement oui
cette droite
je pense pas que nous soyons si éloigné
que ça dans nos convictions mais
effectivement à titre personnel je ne
pourrais pas quitter mon parti pour
toutes les raisons légitimes qu'ils
évoquent mai mais moi j'ai l'intimé
conviction que on va dire une importante
majorité de la droite ne se sent pas
représenté par les convictions d'eric
zemmour et je crois que ça devrait
interroger valérie pécresse dans le fait
d'avoir de ses principaux lieutenants
qui puisse à un moment appelé à soutenir
eczéma encore une fois c'est pas un
jugement dans les valeurs que chacun
porte mais pour moi nous faisons
peut-être effectivement
centre mais pardon la droite fait
aujourd'hui un grand écart et je crois
qu'elle doit s'interroger profondément
sur ses valeurs sûres ce qu'elle doit
incarner combien de combien d'élèves ont
rejoint ont rejoint zemmour aujourd'hui
non mais combien appelle à voter pour
zemmour au second tour il y en a très
très peu il y en a très très peu parce
qu'il ya un socle est un socle de droite
on vous savez très bien on va papa
rentrer dans la dans la dans l'arène ya
des intérêts et losilla ya des intérêts
de tous les intérêts dans la
circonspection et les intérêts je suis
pas combien
de 56 la politique c'est pas le sujet
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui notre
candidat c'est marie perez il ya un
socle des rues autour d'elle s'il ya
trois quatre cinq personnes qui quittent
valérie pécresse pour x ou y raison ça
vous arrivera aussi on peut pas en faire
une généralité on peut pas dire un
problème à droite philippe non mais bien
sûr
c'est dommage pour les frontières d'un
continent les frontières et et dieu soit
loué que vous avez érigé face à marine
le pen je m'interroge de la porosité
qu'il y ait entre vous et régler mais on
sait tous ce vase bah je pense que c'est
un vrai sujet pour l'avenir des
républicains de savoir où est ce qu'ils
se positionnent est ce que finalement
ils viennent challenge et emmanuel
macron sur son propre terrain où est ce
qu'ils deviennent challenge et eric
zemmour est marine le pen
non si jamais levé l'état ce n'était pas
au deuxième tour bon c'est que ça ça va
provoquer une crise de la droite je sais
pas je veux pas répondre encore une fois
parce que j'ai laissé tomber
mais c'est mon mari qui est ce que ces
vins capable de navigation il enfin
j'veux dire quand un candidat quand
accordé d'année pour second tour ça crée
forcément une crise nous avons connu
cette crise ne nous y n'était pas eu
lieu jeudi regardez ce parti socialiste
depuis un certain temps non mais ça va
vraiment content ya un candidat qui
n'est pas au second tour ça crée des
crises il sacré toujours une crise une
recomposition peut-être peut-être à une
recomposition des valeurs encore plus
peut-être différent mais on tiendra à
maquereau on retiendra c'est pas zemmour
qu'on ne challenge rasé moi aussi et le
pen bien évidemment parce qu'elle est à
l'extrême droite nous nous sommes sur le
point central de la de l'échiquier
politique est haut et à droite également
il ya des sensibilités pourquoi
acceptons de gauche plurielle pour qu'on
accepte qu'on accepte non pas une droite
plurielle mais il exercer ici il faut
faire avec la démocratie pour faire avec
des convictions des gens faire avec des
circonscriptions pour est une
circonscription était probablement plus
à droite que la mienne et pourtant tu es
lui dans cette séquence mans et des deux
députés l air d yves hinse sont élus
dans des circonscriptions pour hilaire a
réfléchi à une mouche
justin bergie bout parce que voilà vous
avez
terminé votre mandat de député est ce
qu'il y aura est ce que il y aurait pas
besoin d'une revalorisation du travail
du parlement
et peut-être de trouver des nouvelles
formes de démocratie on parle beaucoup
dans la compagne de maquereaux à dos qui
se préparerait l'idée notamment de ces
grands débats de dos
supporter un peu en décalage avec avec
certains noms dans mon parti pour le
coup mais moi je crois que il faut pas
casser du sucre sur le mandat de
parlementaire souvent et pardies aucune
attaque personnelle mais souvent
survalorise un peu le rôle de l'élu
local c'est un mandat qui est absolument
fondamental c'est un mandat de proximité
mais je crois qu'il ya aussi moi j'ai
adoré ce mandat j'ai adoré ces cinq
années malgré les crises qu'on a
traversées je me sens pas déconnectés du
terrain je pense que j'ai essayer de
réinventer la façon dont j'ai
interagissaient avec avec mes
concitoyens donc oui je pense qu'il faut
il faut le revaloriser et je pense que
j'ai lu les propos de karl olive dans un
échange précédent qu'il avait avec vous
moi je suis pas en face je crois au non
cumul des mandats parce que je crois que
le non cumul ça ne les remet au boulot
si moi je suis bien moi je suis le docu
ville pour le cumul possible je vais
devenir le livre la seconde parce que je
pense que je l'exclus ça permet de
clarifier finalement qui fait quoi de
démocratie et c'est fondamentalement si
on comprend à conférer parlementaire
mais on tombe parfois de sacrées et dit
qu'ils sont hors sol quoi menacer le son
le son le son alors ça dépend si on est
présent dans sa circonscription sur le
terrain moi je viens de l'élu local cgt
mère je suis conseiller départemental
moi je trouve personnellement que ça m'a
énormément aidé dans mon mandat de
député d'abord parce que je suis arrivé
beaucoup plus tard que que les autres
députés donc je devais rallye
intelligent comme j'arrive en cours donc
que j'ai dû rentrer à 10 l'a perdue et
le temps perdu je les rattrape et
comment parce que je connaissais mon
territoire je connaissais les élus je
connaissais des adjoints jeux concédés
conseillers municipaux les directeurs de
généraux de service les les tout ça que
je connais depuis des années
je pense qu'une tradition française
depuis la révolution qui est cette
espèce de cumul qui lie entre le mandat
national alors peut-être il faut régler
tout ça peut-être que deux mandats dans
le temps d'hillion pourquoi pas tout ça
mais gardez cette espèce de 2 d'un pied
à un pied en national un pied sur le
terrain je trouvais que c'était une
bonne idée je vais pas pleurer tapé du
poing sur la table pour que ça revienne
mais ce que j'ai à par là c'est que moi
je le reconnais j'ai été beaucoup aidé
dans mon mandat de député alors le parce
que j'étais du lot car ce verdict
énormément la guerre d'ailleurs
juridiquement le député est un élu de la
nation c'est pas un délit de sa
circonscription parce que nous sommes
une fraction de la circonscription
nationale je peux aussi je vous rejoins
mari ça a été un mandat passionnant même
si j'ai fait que deux ans il demande un
passionnant avec nous assure et enfin
sonia sur le serait on dit la peur bien
sûr jusqu'à le candidat mais mais
c'était un mandat passionnant et puis la
démocratie française et parlementaires
évolué elle a évolué avec giscard aux
formes 14 avec les questions d'actualité
avec la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel ça a été aussi à ça
évolue avec sarkozy ça évolue encore
encore aujourd'hui c'est une démocratie
vivante je sais je ne fais pas partie de
ceux qui disent que c'est une chambre
d'enregistrement tout le monde dit ça
mais c'est ça la mode de dire ça je
voudrais par une commission la dre
travail est maire denis roger les
rapports au vote on est libres rossi
dans son dos ne pas voter comme sont
comme son petit camarade on a en tout
cas on a nous on n'a pas de consigne de
vote on travaille on a un bon groupe
d'études par trouvé que c'était une
chambre d'enregistrement du tout doit
l'avouer est au demeurant à tous les
échelons je crois parce que souvent dans
la vie municipale aussi on constate que
c'est beaucoup les mêmes qui participe
elle avait eu initial je crois qu'on ya
quand même un sujet sur lequel que nous
n'avons pas apporté de réponse encore
vraiment optimales c'est patent de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement ou
la mise en place des politiques
publiques parce que ça je pense que
beaucoup a été fait et encore ça peut
encore évoluer mais beaucoup et fait
c'est comme on associe les citoyens à la
vie démocratique les consultations
publiques que vous pouvez vous engager
parfois c'est du frais même visage qu'on
voit moi je me rappelle on a fait une
tentative un peu de conseil citoyen et
ses 300 personnes au sort dans les
listes électorales pour avoir à peine 15
réponses donc c'est un peu frustrant
parce que il ya nous notre ancrage local
mais il ya aussi notre envie d'interagir
avec des gens qui participent peut-être
devenir plus lointaine de la vie
politique qui vont voter certes mais qui
aimeraient être davantage associés aux
débats qui trouve pas forcément le temps
parce que chacun a ses contraintes
personnelles professionnelles etc et ça
je crois que voilà il ya encore quelque
chose sur lequel on doit travailler de
comment est ce qu'on fait activement
participé les syriens moi je compte
faire revivre le rip machin truc j'y
crois pas du tout mes gars il ya quelque
chose à creuser sur effectivement
comment est ce qu'on fait vivre la
démocratie merci
heureusement voilà
parler avec vous des de la politique
pénitentiaire puisqu'on avait fait un
rapport sur ce sujet je viendrai avec
grand plaisir merci merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup philippe benassaya et à très
vite pour un nouveau 2022 vu par
[Musique]